and straight guys or no are you guys you  a lot of people ask me they're big fans  of you guys whenever somebody says do  you know Chan giantiago yeah those are  those guys are awesome super funny and  they go are they a couple  dude we've uh We've ventured in we've  tried it we've experimented  um but as much as we'd love to be a  couple I just don't think it works what  wouldn't work I think the fact that he  is a penis that's a big No-No for you  yeah I think that's a block that  society's put into us and he pushes it a  little bit more like one time he's like  we gotta try and kiss and he you you're  a little bit more kind of like no no  dude if we tried this don't do it dude  oh whoa you know what it is you're a  passionate dude okay you grabbed his  face was so like genuine no not again  did you like it more now  yeah it just makes me feel good to know  that you hate it so much